[Applause]
welcome hello Paul
I have a question for you okay you were
not a sabbatical I went on a sabbatical
I did that really the first long
sabbatical you're like no not the first
in my life but the first and 15 years
Nemec one okay and and so what happened
what happened yeah how did you come back
so what happened what changed what
changed so this is so so I took three
months off and I first I went to Bali
and I saw those amazing rice terraces
that there was a long now lecture about
but the really big thing that changed
for me and was in the middle going to a
on a silent retreat in Big Sur down at
Newcomb old Olli which is a which is a
monastery about 20 minutes south of a
salon and I for me did the thing that
was the scariest which was to be by
myself and to be quiet you know some
people would climb rocks and you know do
other things to test themselves and and
and what I needed to do was that and
I've faced some of the things inside me
that have really been holding me back
and that's probably too private to talk
about here oh this edge slightly away
from that questions oh I mean why is it
scary why was it scary and the reason
I'm asking the question is I think
underneath the surface a lot of the
world is scared right now yeah you know
there's also much fear and fear is
informing activity and demagoguery and
rhetoric you are so right you're so
right
and that's a good it is a good segue
from what we were just talking about
[Music]
well I mean I think that you know what I
just my brain just flashed to a dinner
conversation I had last night and I'm
think there's a connection and maybe
you'll you know what will help you you
know because some of what was I was you
know really thinking about was really
was more mortality right I mean it's
what do you you know what am I most
scared of wasting my life at some level
and and the preciousness of life and and
you know getting to a different
experience of it and so I was having
dinner conversation last night about
this incredible thing with these miners
this week and how the whole world was
riveted by this and why why was it in
what happened in that moment and our
friend we were having dinner with said
what was like watching all those people
be born they were just came out of the
dark and they were born the technology
worked and community was there and there
was no downside you know it was just joy
and there was something so primal about
it and I wonder if there's something
primal in this moment that has that's
beyond just the the fear of that so many
people have in the great pain that so
many people have economically that we're
that that people sense that something
else is this is going on no no you've
been thinking about this for a long time
don't we all I mean computers here Peter
is saying how he's so optimistic but the
world isn't right now no and the you've
been involved with futurism and you know
and before sabbatical after spell before
Silas after Silas in other words in your
background in journalism and really in
communicating and really expressively
it's so well if I may say so you know
how to move how to transform how to
change how to look forward to
organizations more recently philanthropy
now that you've come through this what
do you want to express me who do you
want to be after that experience because
if we spoke about this before obviously
I know about it so that's so boy there's
so much to say um I think the thing that
would be good to talk about its
community so who do I want to be I want
to be able to be a present member of a
community working on transformation
right so because I think that I mean
you've said before that we're at this
moment in history where we're moving
from a place that's been about power and
privilege to where you know you're
incredible Blessed unrest the and and
you've also said which I also feel we
have what we need we have the resources
we have the talent we have the money we
have the energy and yet we're so stuck
to get through to the next level of the
things we have to deal with we were
trapped in these systems that are you
know not gonna work in the world that's
coming about and when I think about the
things I've learned in in these years
about in any great business that I've
been part of or any nonprofit or you
know something like long now every every
group of people that ever gets something
done
there's a wonderful larger community
that surrounds the thing itself whether
it's a an idea or an organization or you
know I move movement there's this larger
community and somehow we've got to get
to the place that we understand what is
the community that we're part of I mean
so one of the things I spent time you
know just coming to grips with after all
this outside and thinking you know of
scenarios and stuff I had a
I had a fully inside-out experience of
just saying to myself you know just an
ordinary human being just like everybody
else not better I'm not worse and isn't
that wonderful and what does that mean
is my responsibility to be an ordinary
human being now if that makes any sense
but it was that a source of happiness
for you and you it was a great yes it
was a great relief actually and but
there's something about figuring you
know we just heard this wonderful you
know set of things about the community
of the wikimedia this amazing miracle of
that has come about I worry about the
limits of bottom-up change but I I just
how are we gonna get unstuck Paul I mean
what gives you hope about that I you
know it's not just me because I do
public speaking and I know that the
expected payoff you know from my people
hired me you and my audiences hope yeah
they do not want you here you stand up
for 40 minutes and then leave just
completely depressed you know and I can
do that pretty well actually and
in fact when I when I first wrote a
college of Commerce it was turned back
by my editor and saying this is too dark
and I sent it to a reader who was in
Alabama actually and southern girl and
she was just reading the manuscript and
she said you know she would call back to
Paul I love your book but I have to read
the first four chapters in the sunshine
and so I realize that there is a
figure-ground contextual thing is like
you there is a lot of challenging stuff
going on right now I mean we can go over
it we don't need to probably has been
gone over earlier today but the thing is
what do you how do you contextualize it
what holds it you know what is the
vessel in which you hold the rapid
deterioration of climate of biodiversity
of the oceans of equity of income
polarization of the many types of
islands that we don't hear about which
is a violence to the land and violence
to the body through body burden so it
goes on and on and on and we when we
just dwell on the different aspects of
how in a sense we're coming apart we
don't really have a way to hold it
except perhaps community perhaps
religion and its truest form not in its
beliefs cults form but in the sense of
practice you know are those things that
hold it but the thing about hope to me
is that I wonder if really hope is
actually helpful because hope is really
kind of a mask for fear and fears the
mask for hope and some of they can't
they're kind of they kind of go together
and wonder if even hope is because
everybody's always offering some new
version new brand of hope
you know not everybody about I mean
that's what the you know the attempt is
and I'm wondering if that isn't so a
part of that different form of
attachment and kind of a delusion rather
than actually just seeing things the way
they are and saying how interesting yeah
it's really it is really interesting
where we are right now I mean not that
we would all agree does that's okay in
fact we shouldn't but just that if we
look at the facts that the data
at the dynamics themselves talk about
the you know Chinese you know it again
may you live in interesting times I mean
we we do but it is more than just inform
me now it's more about well looking at
the array of things that out there we'll
keep working on things that are worthy
of failure instead of trying to endeavor
to do things that are trivial so it so I
think it's a very yeah well I mean you
know it is then you know it's very
interesting all the happiness for
certain mean that there is something so
cultural in this country the the pursuit
of happiness the the you know it's the
the see on the bright side you know and
there's something so many of the great
entrepreneurs I know or great
entrepreneurs because they do they
refuse to see anything except the worst
thing can happen in a day and a great
entrepreneur stands up and say wow it
was great so we're gonna do it you know
it's just that's how they keep
themselves going and yet I think if we
don't look with clear eyes at where we
are and one of the things that's wrong
with our politics is that nobody's can
stand up and say that they get creamed
when when a grown ups tries to stand up
and say here's what's actually going on
so what happened to journalism where
truth tellers get creamed what's that
where truth tellers get creamed what
happened oh well you know it's
I mean journalism has it isn't the
journalism it's the amplification of the
messages right so the the the you know
the transformation that has happened in
the last 20 years from the only way you
could ever get a message out was through
journalism to 24 you know to the to the
now all the the media has become the
culture right so in journalism is a
shrinking part of the overall media
culture so we have well we actually
have now is a kind of pornographic
information culture right and and and so
all them the any any bad message gets so
amplified or any it's the other side of
the goodness of transparency we have
transparency absolutely run wild and
crazy and so I think we're seeing a
bunch of unintended consequences of the
technology as much as having to do
anything with with you know Stewart I
think it was in Media Lab wrote or one
of the things he said in the 80s when
the new technology rolls in you're
either part of the steamroller part of
the road and that really made a big
impression on me when I was trying to
think about the future of journalism
back in the early 90s and but I think
that that yeah but the steamroller has
taken a lot of other things with it as
well and some of the civility in the
culture is a is part of it a story I
can't get out of my head right now in
the last few months is I just saw an old
friend of mine who is a was the only
journalist from the New York Times who
did great stuff on Watergate you know so
it was a Washington Post story and he
was a civil rights reporter and he
worked at the Watergate and he worked on
Watergate and he so he's a great
investigative reporter and of that that
generation of journalists and he's now
retired and he lives in Southwest
Virginia and he's on the board of
university of a public university and i
sat at lunch and listen to him talk
about how nothing could get done because
you can't actually have a conversation
in public right and and you can't have a
conversation to private either right and
so that the the sort of sense of there's
no secrets has has also got its limits
anyway that's a starting to be a rant
and I'll stop what else is on your mind
Paul but you are a journalist I mean
that is your training your background
your I mean in a great show so what are
you gonna do where do you well I left
journalism for a variety of reasons I
was pretty sure
that journal is the fate of journalism
was going to be controlled by forces
outside journalism and outside the
journalism profession so when when I
really started to understand the inter
Tet Internet in 92 93 so I thought well
if I care about journalism to start
working on the understanding those
things and what the business model is
going to be to support great journalism
in the future because the business model
that used to support it is going to be
killed
and and then I realized that what we
actually need in in most is not so much
to point out what's wrong we need to
light a flame under the things that can
make it better and that journalism is
not the right vehicle for that I think
it's people who you know it's the kinds
of things that you've done it's starting
things it's its ideas its new businesses
its new technologies it's the social
entrepreneurs it's the social movements
it's the it's it's all the people who
are who are who are putting their I want
it to be shoulder to shoulder with the
people who were actually solving the
problems rather than pointing my finger
at what was wrong because I pointing our
finger was wrong it's not gonna it's
absolutely necessary but it's not gonna
fix it mm-hmm
so just as I also just you know this
gives you a sound you know as a human
being I didn't like being in a position
day in a doubt that constantly was about
mistrust rather than trust I just don't
want to live that way but you know it's
it's it's a it's a terrible problem I
don't I don't know what's gonna because
of the best parts of the journalist or
the things that are being starved right
the scarcity if the most important
question to ask is always what is scarce
and the real scary thing is we're about
we're drowning in this stuff that's
trash and the scarcity we have fewer
reporters reporting you know outside the
United States
what's the business model to support the
bureau and Baghdad you know you know the
the things that are actually being
destroyed the fastest are the things
that we need most as a democracy in your
work with philanthropy
I mean you said that you would like to
be shoulder to shoulder with people who
were actually providing the solutions
and a lot of those solutions are really
funded by the philanthropic community
and most of those movements and civil
society do not have the leverage of
Wikipedia where so little can do so much
yeah it's just an extraordinary thing in
fact so extraordinary that is really one
up still and so but the philanthropic
community it seems to me is like the
last century it's still in the last
century it's not in the century at all
technologically it's still sort of
moving around and feeling it's right and
it's so much about implementation and
implementation is really about not
taking the risk and rapid changes about
innovation and failure for good reason
because all right you're contractually
could and so you have a real divide
between what's on the ground I think in
trying to create innovative social
models and where the flow of funds are
coming from that's right I'm working on
it
so are a lot of people but I think the
one thing I would say to be careful
about is there is no such thing as
philanthropy right we have still a
minute there's no such thing as
philanthropy there's a tremendous
diversity and there is actually great
hope in the Wikipedia model I think for
funding 75% of the money given away in
this country is from individuals and
there I think are going to be models in
the future much like Obama's campaign
where small amounts of money from a lot
of people can fund things if they can
get visible which it goes back you know
in the circle I also think there going
to be more and more new philanthropists
who are going to do things with the
risk-taking way but it is stuck I'm
working on it I think my time is off
okay thank you
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you